[Music]
and here we are
back for another openings explained
lecture i'm nick briscoe your instructor
for tonight and one of the instructors
here at the st
louis chess club and tonight we're going
to be doing a part
two to the rossolimo attack which we
were talking about last week
very theory heavy lecture uh
talking almost the entire time tonight's
going to be a lot lighter
we may not even fill up the whole hour
so if you have any questions from the
last
lecture or from tonight make sure to
drop them in the chat i'll try and get
uh get to them at the end so tonight
we're going to be going over
um the e6 lines in the russell limo
attack
where if you're not familiar it starts
off with pawn to e4
and pawn to c5 knight to f3 knight to c6
and the rasa limo is bishop to b5 and
like we were talking about last week
this is probably
uh probably the best theoretical
alternative to the open sicilian
and last week we were talking about g6
we were talking about knight to f6
talking about what if black goes pawn to
d6 and tries to get some
variation of the moscow but tonight
we're going to be focusing on the move
pawn to e6
because the plans for this are going to
be a little bit different
than all of the others it's a little bit
more unique and would be good for us to
make sure we cover the plan
so let me make sure i switch to the
right chapter here
uh so here we go bishop to b5 and pawn
to e6
now just to recap the the idea behind
bishop to b5 is that
white is putting his bishop on a square
where one he's developing it
and ready to castle on the next move if
so desires
but also the way the knight is here
without d6 being played white is setting
up to
capture the knight and double black's
pawns and hopefully get an advantage off
of the pawn structure
uh why is playing e4 e5 like openings as
white against the sicilians so bad
um it was a question from cameron bruce
uh so one of the reasons why you can't
always play the same setups is because
with e5 they're making a direct
contest for the center and here with c5
they're challenging the center
from the flank so the ideas are
different
uh between the two systems that black
has so there's no one universal chess
opening
otherwise we'd only have one one lecture
for openings explained and that would be
it
so here we are looking at what happens
if white goes bishop to b5
and black goes e6 and we'll go on to
white's moves here there are three kind
of ideas that i have here that branch
off
from this position immediately we're
first going to take a look at the move
knight to c3 and this seems very logical
you just keep developing your pieces
and this is also going to be helping
stop
black's main idea here the reason why
black is going to go
e6 is so they can try and get a d5 push
and recapture
with the pawn make a bigger fight for
the center
compared to like g6 which is the main
line where you're going to be
attacking the center from far away so
knight c3 just develops it's also
getting a little bit more control on the
d5 square here
and black is going to go knight g to e7
and the
one of the ideas is if white takes on c6
then they can recapture with the knight
and then
they won't have doubled pawns on the c
file
we'll see white castle again quick
castle after the miners are developed
and after pawn to a6 here
we can capture captures and then play
pawn to d4 strike in the center try and
open it up a little bit white
is a little bit ahead in development
here with two knights out and
castles while black has made a lot of
pawn moves and white's trying to ask
black you know
what's your idea here uh once i break in
the center i'm going to have a lot of
development what do you have to show for
it
just like most sicilians black is going
to capture open up the c
file for himself later during the game
knight recaptures and queen c7
and in this line it kind of transposes
to timing of sicilian
but the difference here is white has
greater than normal development
the trade-off is that white also doesn't
have their light squared bishop
so this is an idea for black
but not the main line here but you guys
should be aware of it
one of the other ideas here is capturing
on c6
right away and the idea is you're
forcing black to choose what way they're
going to recapture
and depending on what way they're going
to recapture is going to influence the
game now
uh tonight we're going to be looking at
b take c6 i decided not to look at d
takes because
it doesn't really follow with the themes
i'm following for black here if they
take with the d-pawn
then they don't get to play d5 later but
normal development
should suffice for white tier just
castles and you'll play something like
d3
c3 you'll get your bishop to e3 knight
d2
very simple developing moves shouldn't
need to think so hard because black is
not
actively fighting for center control
here
but we'll look at um the pawn uh
b takes oh jumping around here a little
bit b takes
and white now has two options here as
well
we're going to start off with a little
bit of a sideline here that can lead to
an interesting
trap for black to fall into for white to
take advantage of
and that is the move here pawn to b3
the idea is you're going to try and put
your bishop on b2
put some pressure on this a1 to h8
diagonal
have a very nice long range for this
bishop
and here black can go d6 try and
uh i guess open up some of the center
for the bishop you're kind of trapping
your
your dark square bishop but what else is
it really to do you want to solidify
your center
we see pawn to e5 setting up a trap
and the idea is if black takes
white can take back and black may have
thought ahead and been like well wait
dwight uh
white can't take here because queen to
d4
is a fork so we'll give a second for the
chat to see
what the move is here i'm not entirely
sure how well known this trap is i don't
know how quick you guys will get it but
i do want you guys to try and see if you
can find the right move here for white
to continue
musa 20 is saying pawn to c3
if pawn to c3
what are you going to do against queen
takes e5 with check
it's going to be a little bit of a
problem here
all right so we're getting a few more
people in the chat here sandro shock
uh is in here saying bishop to b2
and this is the move this is the trap
that black can fall for
your bishop develops to b2 anyway and it
defends the knight
and you're probably like nick that
you're losing the bishop
yeah we have people in the chat here
saying bishop b2 loses the queen takes
b2
but you guys have to calculate more than
one move ahead
you know yes the bishop is hanging but
now we have a follow-up move
we'll see if you guys can find the
continuation
this is going to be uh seeing if sandro
shock specifically knows
this trap see if they see the follow up
and hopefully we'll get
arthas his his answer to why queen takes
b2
is inadequate
yeah we're getting in the chat here
knight to c3
is the trap and once we take a look at
it
white did give up the bishop on b2 but
when you look at
the position of black's pieces
specifically the queen the queen has
almost nowhere to go
the only escaped square is a three and
here if you try queen to a3 well then
you're met with the finishing move queen
to f3
and the idea is you are threatening to
come down with some mating ideas
uh like take on f7 with the queen and
take on f8 uh you can't just take on f7
and go to d7 because of the bishop on c8
but you are threatening queen takes f7
and in addition
you are threatening queen take c6 where
now that even though you've given up the
bishop this fork is going to result in
you
winning a rook so you're going to be
gaining an exchange here
and white stands much better i guess the
only move where
white has really faltered at least in
the database i'm using the lead chess
database knight e7
and white has faltered here but just
taking on f7 with either the queen or
knight
is going to give white an advantage
based off of initiative
and just the fact that black's king is
being harassed
so there is a little trap there that if
you're unfamiliar with
if you're playing with the black pieces
or if you're trying to play some funny
moves with white
this is something you can try out in
blitz
i don't know how well it would hold up
in a classical tournament after bishop
to b2 your opponent might know what's
going on
and they can just go like queenie for
check
and you probably have to give up your
right to castle if you try going queen
to e2 there's queen takes g2
and probably just even trading on e2
shouldn't be
too horrible for black so
nice little trap again i don't know how
well it would hold up in classical but
in blitz
definitely a surprise weapon here
now like i said that's not the main line
that's just one of the sidelines
um the main line here is to castle so
after
you know bishop takes right away and the
b pawn takes
you castle and now black normally
follows up with d5 right away
you can go d5 right away and white can
just defend their center
the idea is if black takes you can take
right back and after a queen trade
white is doing completely fine they
still have space here on the king side
they have development
they already have an entire file so
black doesn't really want to take here
instead they'll defend with something
like knight to f6
you can get pawn to e5 hitting the
knight and after knight to d7 your
knight is safe you're putting pressure
on the pawn
so white over defends and now after
bishop to e7
black's going to castle short and white
is going to continue with moves probably
like c4 or bishop f4
and even knight to c3 is fine here
but uh going d5 right away is definitely
an idea
for black the other idea that i want to
focus on is
knight to e7 which is the other idea of
why e6 is played so your
g knight can go to e7 get some more
control over the center
and the problem here though is that
you're blocking your dark square bishop
which just means it's going to take
longer for you to castle so
something like knight g6 is going to be
played and then bishop to e7 and then
castle short
you're not going to want to castle queen
side don't even think about it with
these pawns missing
on b7 there's just this huge hole i
don't see how you're going to stop
something like pawn to c3 and queen a4
effectively so
white will go pawn to b3 and again we
see this idea of fiance the queen side
bishop
for easier development we get knight to
g6
bishop to b2 hitting the g pawn which
means that
black can't exactly develop the bishop
right away if they try and go bishop to
e7
just bishop takes g7 taking the pawn
rook to g8 and after the bishop goes
back
i'm not sure what black is gaining after
giving up this pawn
so if your opponent's not careful and
they try and develop and castle you can
just ruin that plan by taking on g7
so instead of doing that black should
probably play the move
um pawn to d5 and this is a move that i
took a look at
and it's definitely not played as much
i think this is probably one of the best
tries just fighting for the center right
away
white should defend the e pawn and now
black can go pawn to f6 now again we're
kind of
ignoring ben feingel's general rule of
never play f6
this is making sure that the bishop
cannot take on g7
so it's limiting the bishop's scope and
also preparing for
something like yeah bishop e7 and castle
short or you might even try and consider
king f7
going rook f8 later in king to g8 and
castling by hand
so f6 uh while it may look like your
opponent's
uh ignoring general rules this is not
too terrible for black here
after something like pawn to e5 to try
and break up the pawns
try and give life back to this bishop
bishop to e7 just
defending f6 now we'll see both sides
just develop their pieces
to kind of natural squares this knight
does come to a4 to put pressure on c5
um and here we see black castle finally
and we see pawn to d3 white's gonna
probably put the queen on d2
and try and get some sort of pressure
going along the diagonals here but
after something like f takes e5 where
the pawn's protected i think
black has a bit of an advantage here
nothing too crushing
um you know a lot of doubled pawns here
in the center but this is a nice pawn
center for black i don't think this is
um
too terrible for black at all again
probably slightly better
but just an idea uh if they don't go d5
right away the other ideas that have
been tried is um
pawn to f6 right away so pawn to f6 has
been tried but
is met with either e5 trying to break it
up right away
uh this was played i think in 2002
against cuartas
goldko in one of the olympiads yeah the
2002 olympiad
and uh really white just got regular
development here they get knight to d2
there's no need for them to go knight c3
and a4 uh they just go d2 make sure this
bishop's still on the diagonal this is
fine
and queen c7 and here you have a chess
game
if they don't try f6 the other idea
that's been tried is bishop to e7 but
this like i said uh is bad just because
it hangs the pawn
so not good enough
so that's kind of what can happen if um
white captures
right away now let's take a look at some
of the other ideas white has they don't
need to capture
we already looked at knight c3 so i
guess it's time to look at the main line
with castles
okay so
castle's king side and black has a few
ideas but the one we're going to be
looking at
is knight g to e7 again one of the
reasons e6 is played i want to make sure
i get that point across
your opponent is playing e6 to go knight
e7 and play d5
and here again white has a few different
branches they can go
down here c3 is an idea this is one of
the major variations that black should
be aware of
where after pawn to a6 the bishop goes
to a4
and then you see pawn to b5 hitting the
bishop and it comes back to c2
kind of something that's not quite
unlike the rui lopez
and we see bishop to b7 speaking of the
rui lopez it looks like niebus is asking
if i have any plans to teach the rui
lopez
i don't have any currently maybe in the
distant future
but i have a bunch of other openings
lined up for the next few weeks
but okay bishop b7 and we have uh
quite a few moves in here that are uh
theory we'll see
black trying to expand in the center
white kind of clamp it down with pawn to
e5
black trying to bust through and white
is going to get this bishop
active on e4 so a lot of moves with the
light squared bishop
but they all come with a purpose all
come with pressure and then the queen
side pieces are going to develop later
again
something that's not too unlike a lopez
or a
yoko pianissimo so i'll go through the
rest of the moves here just for
illustrative purposes
i'm not going to be looking at them too
terribly deep tonight
just because last week we did go over a
lot of theory
um but we see a lot of trades in the
center
but both sides eventually get all their
pieces developed and here we enter
um almost another game where white is
slightly better
um but both sides have bishop pairs it's
just that uh black has this isolated
queen's pawn that's going to be a target
so white is slightly better here in the
end game but
something black needs to be worried
about or not worried about just be aware
of
that c3 is a move here
another idea that's been tried is knight
to c3 here
and the difference between this position
and the previous position is that this
knight is on
e7 and this bishop is still on b5
and after knight to d4 this maneuver
we looked at a lot last week and
variations where it didn't work but here
it does seem to work for black you
capture on d4
capture on d4 and here you just go
knight to e2 putting pressure
on the pawn a6 getting tempo off the
bishop
bishop goes back knight to c6
you might be tempted to go b5 here but i
don't see what black is really gaining
out of this bishop b3 and
maybe you're looking for the plan of
bishop to
b7 but d3 just holds on and you're gonna
have to move this knight
anyway to develop your bishop
so i think if you just go knight to c6
here leaving this capture open this
capture is going to
help black because they can bring a pawn
closer to the center to break through
pawn to d3 bishop to c5 just holding on
to the pawn
and then pawn to c4 has been played in
the game watson none from 1996
where black continued rook to b8 which
is a bit of a mistake
the bishop develops with tempo the pawn
has to come to d6
and this dark story bishop really i'm
really wishing it could be doing more
for black here it's really not doing
much kind of looking like a tall
pawn not really having much control over
the position
after pawn to b4 bishop b4 knight takes
d4
white has a better game because they
just traded off a b pawn for a center
pawn
or rather the c pawn but the c pawn was
influencing the center
so i'm considering it to center upon
here and white ended up
going on to have a serious advantage
here
so knight c3 is a is an interesting idea
here as well
but we're going to look at the main line
now rook to e1
and the idea here is just reinforce this
e4 pawn
maybe you're going to drive it up to e5
later and
i guess one of the main ideas is if they
go d5 here
you're okay capturing because now you're
opening up the file
for your rook and this shouldn't be a
problem for white at all the knight
should probably take because if you take
with the pawn
this is going to be annoying the knight
is not really defending the knight on c6
and knight to e5 is even a possibility
here
not the best move breaking open with d4
and just expanding
opening up lines for the rest of your
pieces for rapid development is going to
be the way to go
but i'm just demonstrating some of the
problems with capturing with the pawn
this pin
can be very annoying
so uh you shouldn't go d5 you go a6 and
hit the bishop
and now we see the bishop come to f1 so
i guess the general
idea is that um when they play a6 if
you're able to bring the bishop to f1
you might want to preserve the bishop
keep the bishop pair if you can't go
bishop to f1
and the choice is taking on c6 or going
to a4
it seems like in most of these lines you
just capture
capturing isn't going to uh be too
terrible for white and most of these
lines
i couldn't find a line where black just
like blows white out of the water if
they capture
so uh if you can go bishop f1 i'd say go
for it if you can't
then trading on c6 is fine but here
bishop f1
is possible and now we have
pawn to d5 um i do have a note
on bishop takes here i know i was just
saying taking shouldn't be too bad
here is one of the slight exceptions if
you take on c6 now
uh it's helping black play d5 earlier i
forgot about this
where after the b pawn takes just d5 is
coming and if you capture
the the second c pawn is going to
recapture so
my apologies i didn't catch my note
there this is one of the
exceptions uh bishop to f1
and pawn to d5 breaking open in the
center getting that space
and now giving the true contest and now
all of black's moves are making sense
for why they played e6
and knight to e7 again white should
capture open up the file for the rook
knight takes and then pawn to d4 trying
to get that space back make another
challenge in the center
they shouldn't concede it too early we
see the knight go back
to f6 and what exactly is the reason
behind this
black could capture uh and after night
captures
you can make a few developing moves this
is fine but i think
one of the main ideas behind knight two
f6 here is
probably just to keep an eye on the
center squares
um in case of pawn comes i think this uh
this push giving white this option is
going to help
and then also maybe get your bishop onto
d6 but you really want to get
some pressure on this pawn it looks like
bishop to e3 just to defend it
and then bishop e7 developing
and here is uh just a couple
more moves of the main line here just
pawn to c4
expanding in the center you're going to
be castling as black
knight to c3 captures captures
and after knight to e5 not allowing
a trade for white i don't think that
would be too great for either side
black should just go to e5 keep the
pieces on the board start maintaining
the pressure
and then you're going to get your bishop
out in the future but
this is the main line of e6
in the russell limo attack and this was
kind of everything we
we didn't get to cover last week i know
this was a lot shorter only about half
an hour
instead of our full hour here but i
wanted to make sure that i didn't leave
you guys hanging with this
major variation for black so i'm going
to open up
our time here to the chat
on any questions you have in the
rossolimo
maybe we'll branch off and talk about
other openings generally but this is
really just an open floor for you guys
now since we covered
since we covered all the lines for the
russell limo
i think we also have people checking us
out on twitch tonight
but i don't see any any comments in the
twitch chat
let's look through the the youtube chat
here
uh talk on the knight or sicilian uh i
would talk about the najdorf if caleb
denby didn't do
a crazy 10-part series on it
so i'm not going to talk about the
sicilian night or if we have a whole
10-part series
once this goes up on youtube i'm sure
ben or danny or someone
can include a link to that but uh yeah
we have a bunch of videos on the night
or if i'm not going to talk about it
sandra shock why isn't there a german
opening i don't know
i'm not the guy who names the openings
i'm just the guy who who talks about
them
make a video on the gyoka piano
uh i might do that uh the italian is one
of the openings i've been looking at
to talk about but it does have a bit
more theory than all the ones we've
talked about that might be one we have
to split up into a couple
couple nights like this um is there
anything on the rostelimo though i want
to make sure we get all the russell emo
questions
please mention the link of najdorf i i
did it's a ten part series
on our on our youtube page uh i wish i
had the the playlist link memorized but
i don't
just look up caleb denby neidorf and
then i'm sure one of the parts will pop
up
but this is not this is not a naidorff
lecture tonight
okay here we go e king master puppets
what is to be done with the bishop on f1
uh good question so this bishop on f1
definitely not as active as other
positions you'll see the light squared
bishop in
such as the italian or the rui lopez
where either it's helping to attack on
f7
or it's helping support the center
positionally
here on f1 the bishop is guarding the c4
pawn which is going to probably be
black's next target excuse me uh be
black's next target
after probably bishop to d7 and rook to
c8 b3
will solidify this overall but the
bishop is also preventing a b5 expansion
from black so this bishop is really not
going to see
any play soon but later
maybe after maybe two sets of minor
pieces maybe a pair of rooks come off
the board something like g3
and bishop to g2 this bishop is going to
have massive control over the center you
can probably even do this
um as soon as probably even this
position let's check it out here
what happens if i go g3 in this position
it looks like after g3 right away
one of the knights can go to g4 and
they're trying to take on e3
so maybe g3 right away isn't going to
work maybe
pawn to h3 to keep these knights away
and then like i said
later you're going to probably go g3 and
bishop g2
is probably going to be an easy way to
get it out but if you rush it
too soon you might experience some
weaknesses on the king side like i said
you probably want to trade off some sets
of minor pieces first
so very nice uh question there
thank you for the compliments nebraska's
always a pleasure to give these lectures
um
hey buddy is asking for theory on the
bong cloud
i might have ideas with that so keep
your eyes out over the next
next few weeks
can i expand on ideas in the middle game
for this opening
so um at least for the e6 lines which
like i said we're focusing on tonight uh
black is going to try and go for that d5
once they get d5 and make that fight
for the center you might see some
liquidation
like this but like uh like we were just
looking at uh in the long term
white might be trying to trade off some
minor pieces maybe a set of nights
to i guess ease up some of the pressure
so that way it gives more flexibility
for your light square bishop to move
around
if we were to play game from this
position
what would i be expecting
as white i almost want to go b3 just to
make sure i don't have any
problems with the c pawn but that may
run into bishop to b4
so maybe i just go queen to b3 and try
and target the queen side bonds here
as well but it's hard to give a
direct direct um approach to the
position
and then for all the other lines in the
ross limo we did cover those
and the main plans for those in our last
lecture
uh is the carlson caruana match a good
example to learn the rossolimo
i would say when you have the number one
and two chess players in the world
playing any chess game i think it's
going to be good to take a look at
to see the plans for both sides
especially if all of the games ended in
draws
usually draws are going to be the
highest quality chess games
just because both sides are playing very
well i think any games by them are going
to be worth taking a look at
what is the best sicilian defense
variation for black
is the question by uh was it devan
i hope i'm saying that correctly um
i have my personal opinions um i'm going
to be a dedicated dragon player for
probably as long as i live but if you
play any
sicilian variation then you run a lead
chess analysis on it it will tell you
any move
other than a6 is dubious
but the najdorf is probably going to be
probably going to be the best variation
definitely the most respected and
probably the reason why most players
would avoid the open sicilian
and play openings such as the rossolimo
here and avoid
all that theory
so another good question from the
youtube chat
okay i'm popping back over to the twitch
tag i see some people
type in here uh
ilmadado uh is asking when is it good to
play bishop
takes c6 for white like i said usually
um it doesn't hurt white too much
what you do want to avoid is in these e6
lines uh like i said there was that one
exception we had
earlier where did it go i want to find
it
where did it go in my notes
here we go so uh in the line where um
if you don't capture right away you play
uh castles and then they play knight ge7
and rook to e1 they play a6
here you don't really want to capture on
c6 because after b
captures they get a quick d5 and they
get to challenge you in the center right
away
so if you can go bishop f1
you'd rather go bishop f1 otherwise
taking on c6 shouldn't pose a great
problem i don't think it was ever a real
problem
in any line other than e6
but yeah when e6 is played you do want
to be a little cautious and make sure
black can't just get this
expanse in the center right away
so uh yeah that should answer
what looks to be probably the only
question from the twitch chat
looks like youtube has more here uh is
f4 an
option to pressure the e5 knight so i'm
assuming that's going to be
about the final position knight e5
is f4 an option what do i think of it
immediately
immediately i think f4 is a little too
aggressive
um let's see
if we go f4 right away this has been
played before
but it looks like black gets a serious
advantage after going knight to
g4 here and then threatening to take
probably
what what is white's better bishop
usually most sicilians this dark square
bishop for white
is it superstar probably the best minor
piece on the board in here black is just
threatening to trade it off
and you can't exactly just move it back
it looks like if you try moving it back
to
c1 we don't want to go to d2 and just
give this knight away for free
they can come in with e5 it looks like
and expand
if you take we run into bishop c5
and we're going to be losing this knight
if we take on f6
then bishop d4 check and now knight f2
so one thing i don't like about f4
is that it makes bishop to c5 a lot
stronger
so yeah knight g4 and then whatever you
do like bishop c5
just pinning the knight is going to be
very strong so i don't think f4
i don't think f4 is going to be the play
here i think just playing it slowly this
knight really isn't doing anything to
hurt your position too much
other than trying to go to geforce like
i said h3 is gonna probably be my
recommendation here
uh and just play it slow and safe
there's no need to be over aggressive
and try and
uh shoot these knights away and you
might run into some trouble
if you try and force force things from
your opponent
uh see uh is this uh
jean-michel royer maybe again i'm
horrible with pronouncing names a
question has nothing to do with this do
you think anybody can reach 2000 if they
put in the work
i think most people can reach class a
maybe
experts if they put in the work really
just focusing on not
hanging your pieces is at least
something that
most of my friends who are masters say
i'm not a master myself
i'm not over 2 000 yet getting there
hopefully so i can't speak from my
personal experience
but from what i've asked from very
strong players most people think
people can get to 2000 just by focusing
on not hanging their pieces
or letting their opponents just get away
with the initiative
is the alkyne defense good it's playable
i think if it has a
if an opening has a name it's usually
playable unless it's like um
the grab or the wandering king um
kind of troll openings
what if queen to c7 or queen to b6 did i
cover those moves uh
richard dickinson is asking in the
youtube chat uh yes i did cover queen to
c7 queen to c7 is a very um
uh interesting idea here where it's
going to kind of transpose to a timing
of sicilian which we haven't covered
or at least i haven't covered on the
channel but if you look up any
time in off systems it's going to be
very similar but white is usually going
to have
more development because of just the
weird transposition black makes
spending a few extra unnecessary moves
to get a timing of
i seem too strong for 15.37 uh well
my uscf right now is 16.50
but the last tournament uh i had i like
uh almost tied for first
in a u18 against other 1800s
um so i while i would like to say i'm
underrated i mean my ratings 1650 i'm
going to say i'm 16.50
check back in with the twitch chat see
if they have any more questions over
here
nope uh all right
i'll take it over back to youtube
there's still questions coming in so i'm
going to still keep this going
as soon as the questions start to dry up
we're going to wrap up the openings
class
would we get a deep
would we get deep into the martial
attack and its variants
also thanks for all the knowledge um so
the marshall attack and its variants
that is something i do want to cover
just because it is uh opening that can
just
blow someone out of the water if they
don't know what they're talking about
but
i want to make sure that uh i'm really
trying to get the best moves there for
you the best variations it's been
very heavily analyzed almost to i think
almost to a draw right
every time but i want to make sure i can
get the full picture for everybody i
don't just want to be like hey here's
the main line
and deal with it because you're
realistically if your opponent is you
know below 1500
they're not going to play the main line
all the way down you need to make sure
you understand
all the sidelines as well and why those
why those don't work
so the marshall attack is something i
want to try and get into for you guys
okay um not seeing any more questions
come through we'll check twitch chat one
last time
nothing over there so i think we might
be able to
wrap this up early and move over to uh
twitch where we'll uh start with the
winner's circle it's one of our new
lectures here that i'm i'm leading here
uh we're covering the tournament games
of winners of famous tournaments in
history or very important tournaments in
history
right now we're going over the 53
candidates tournament in zurich where
we're looking at the games of vasilis
mislove who is
was a world champion and ended up
winning this candidates tournament
one of the strongest tournaments of its
time in history
uh this is going to be our second night
we're going to be looking at games four
through six so make sure to join us over
on
twitch.tv stl chess club for that
thank you for stopping in for openings
explained we're going to move over to
twitch
get that lecture going for you guys have
a good night
[Music]
you